is the night that should deliver the
coup de gras to donald trump's campaign
to hold on to the white house a curfew
has come into effect
after a night of violence his support
donald trump supporters massed
outside congress and then forced their
way in
leading to the suspension of the session
which was due to confirm joe briden
as the next president one person has
been
killed after being shot inside the
capital and improvised explosive devices
have been found the chaos followed
senior republicans including the vice
president
making clear they would not overturn the
results
of the presidential election
it was literally an attack on democracy
supporters of donald trump scuffling
with police inside the united states
capital
outside thousands have besieged the
building
even at a time when everything seems
remarkable in american politics
these are astonishing scenes
inside the chamber security personnel
with guns drawn at the windows
members of congress sheltering in place
on the floor people taking
what they could as souvenirs at least
one person was shot
critically injured police say others
were injured in the clashes
the chaos and violence indicative of a
country riven and a slice of the
population
unwilling to accept defeat they've been
sent on their way by a president almost
two weeks to the moment when he'll leave
the white house for the final time
continuing to make the case he didn't
really lose at all
now it is up to congress to confront
this egregious assault
on our democracy and after this
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you we're going to walk down
we're going to walk down anyone you want
but i think right here we're going to
walk down
to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them what he called the evidence
has already been debunked but
as he was speaking his own vice
president was taking his place in
congress for what's usually a formality
of certifying his and trump's defeat
would he adhere to the constitution or
bow to trump's pressure to somehow try
and overturn the election
we got our answer before he started
speaking
that's my statement yes here it is is my
statement out he says
that statement that he did not have the
authority to reject the votes
still plenty of republicans continue to
object
is the objection in writing and signed
by a senator
yes it is it is
it would mean hours of debate but the
outcome is inevitable
and senior republicans now defying trump
this election were overturned by mere
allegations from the losing side
our democracy would enter a death spiral
it wasn't long after the process was
suspended because of the violence
outside
let me be very clear the scenes of chaos
of the capital
do not reflect a true america
do not represent who we are
what we're seeing are a small number of
extremists
dedicated to lawlessness this is not
dissent
it's disorder it's chaos
it borders on sedition and it must
end now the calls for calm from the
president came long after the violence
had started
i know your pain i know you're hurt
we had an election that was stolen
from us it was a landslide election
and everyone knows it especially the
other side
but you have to go home now we have to
have peace
we have to have law and order we have to
respect our great
people in law and order we don't want
anybody hurt
but never is the anger and division in
america being quite so direct
and two weeks out from this place
hosting what should be the peaceful
transition of power
what are the chances all of this ends
with donald trump's presidency
greg milam sky news washington